Rain bearing no secrets,
Falling from a sky without answers.
It’s like an old folktale—a
story coming to life.
At the time,
I didn’t know where I belonged.
I merely floated by with a hopeless smile.
On the day that I promised
I’d never turn back
I recall it all like yesterday,
when the walls began to crack
Ever all resolved to just falling,
near gave up along the way
I will protect that smile
That’s piercing towards the clear blue sky.
I don’t know if I’ll
be of any use to you.
I’m not really the main character type,
But by your side is where
I’ll be (standing with you).
I want to sing,
If only solely on bravery.
Can you hear that promise ringing out?
‘cause I just won’t let it die
I don’t know what sort of
future is waiting for us.
I know there’ll be some
difficult times ahead,
But even so, I still believe
(fight by your side)
Even if I’ve only got half the courage
I want to push forward.
I’m certain I’ll never leave your side.
I’ll be there.